hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israel
heute gibt es einen mini rezept ich
werde fünf minuten show küchlein zu
bereiten das kleine bücher habe ich euch
schon auf instagram hochgeladen und ihr
mal alles sehr begeistert ich stand
jetzt auch gleich mit dem rezept ihr
braucht nur ganz wenige zutaten und ganz
wenig zeit für die schokotörtchen
brauche ich ein 130 gramm zucker etwas
daniel extrakt einen esslöffel heißen
espresso 20 gramm mehl das ist ein
esslöffel 50 von butter und 75 gramm
zarter schokolade
wobei ich hier immer ganz gerne herum
schokolade nehme den die hat mehr
kakaoanteil
und jetzt nehme ich das bild das kommt
in die röhre da kommt sogar mit dazu und
etwas vanille extrakt für den geschmack
jetzt kommt ein esslöffel heißer
espresso mit dazu falls jetzt keine
nespresso mit nimmt einfach einen
esslöffel heißes wasser um den rest aus
trinken und das ganze wird etwa 5
minuten schaumig gerührt und in dieser
zeit kann ich schon mal die schokolade
und butter in einem topf schmelzen
die butter und schokolade sind jetzt
geschmolzen aber sie dürfen nicht auf
kochen also soll nicht zu heiß werden
und die eier mischung ist jetzt auch
fertig ich kenne ich das mehl und die
schokoladen mischung einfach noch kurz
unterhalten
du willst hier drei förmchen und die
werde ich jetzt erstmal einen fetten
beats dann mit etwas zucker ausstreuen
damit törtchen später besser lösen kann
der zucker karamellisiert später am
randen besteht wenn jetzt statt zucker
mehl nehmen würde dann hätte man später
so ein brand aus was hatte ich nicht so
hübsch aussieht und nicht so gut
schmeckt wie zucker jetzt den teig oder
die masse auf die drei portionen
aufteilen
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die förmchen
jetzt vor dem backen mit kurzen
fachstellen für zehn minuten dann bleibt
der kern innen später in den schocker
gütern ein bisschen feuchter und
saftiger ich werde jetzt allerdings
gleich backen ist die shopper kühl sein
werden jetzt im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 175 grad ober unterhitze für zwölf
minuten gebacken auf keinen fall länger
mit der kern in feucht bleibt
die zwischenzeit werde ich jetzt nutzen
und schon mal den frucht spiegel also
die frucht soße zubereiten
dafür habe ich nur drei zutaten und die
gebe ich jetzt wieder einen topf ich
gebe jetzt 100 gramm und tief gefallen
himbeeren einen teelöffel zucker um
jetzt nehmen wir noch zwei ersetzten
wasser oder einen link oder zum beispiel
orangensaft gibt denn hinzu und was 456
minuten aufkochen
das fruchtbare streiche ich jetzt noch
durch ein sieb und wartet dann auf die
fertigen tat hier
die turtle sind jetzt fertig kann sich
anrichten
cpm bisschen butter schokolade also
herren schokolade einfach verschmolzen
werden teller damit dekorieren mit dem
pinsel einmal so drüber fahren dann
kommt das buch curie dran die soße dafür
nehme ich zum deko also ein deko löffel
kann es hier ein spiel ausgehen
natürlich auch mit einem normalen laufen
kann das ist sehr schön drauf bieten
lassen
jetzt kommt das törtchen noch dran dann
ist jetzt einfach ein bisschen den rand
lösung falls es noch hängt
und das ganze könnte jetzt mit einem ins
bad noch dekorieren und jetzt habt ihr
innerhalb von nur 17 minuten ein richtig
leckeres des hergezaubert was ihnen noch
richtig schön feucht ist lecker und
geradezu warm schmeckt mir besonders gut
weil sie es lust auf dieses rezept
bekommen habt dann geht auf 6 - blog.de
da stets noch mal ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch einen guten appetit und
viel spaß danach machen bis zum nächsten
mal
und falls sie jetzt auch lust bekommen
das rezept dann geht auch sallys block
der etat steht es noch mal ganz genau
für euch und ich wünsche euch schon mal
ganz viel spaß und nachmachen und ganz
und falls sie jetzt lust bekommen habt
auf dieses rezept dann geht es mit bloc
täter stets nummer für euch und ich
wünsche euch und falls jetzt auf dieses
rezept bekommen hat dann habt habt mein
gott